in the grand tradition of r2d2 the Iron
Giant and Johnny Five comes another
adorable kid in their pet robot story
only this one's King at tens
Terminator 2 Judgment Day dun dun duh
dun duh dun dun da-dun return to an era
when hard our films were sold to
children you're next John Connor I'm
back
hasta LaVista baby's coming he was full
of things we probably weren't ready to
see and would have been even more
disturbing if it started the studio's
first choice Oh Jay Simpson the journey
to a future so grim the streets are
literally paid with human skulls as the
evil AI Skynet sends a terminator back
in time to kill John Connor whose father
was a man sent back in time to protect
him meaning if the robots really wanted
to kill John
they shouldn't have sent anything to
kill him at all since he never would
have been born
but if Skynet doesn't send back the
first Terminator he wouldn't leave
behind the technology that led to Skynet
existing in the first place
yeah the timelines off dub meet the
t1000 the iPhone of killer cyborgs whose
liquid metal body can take any shape
meaning those ears were a deliberate
choice and the t800 the indestructible
nokia brick phone of killer cyborgs a
stiff emotionless monotone giant that
Arnold Schwarzenegger was bored to play
I know know why you cry
but it's something I can never do full
of awesome features like shotgun Welling
and endless supply of one-liners I'll be
back
come with me if you want to live hasta
la vista baby
a casualty counter that's specific down
to the decimal point for some reason and
detailed files on human anatomy I've
detailed files on human anatomy
except for crying what's wrong with your
eyes or smiling watch these killers
spend the first third of the film in a
cat-and-mouse game that would have you
guessing which one is the good guy
if the trailers hadn't already given it
away once he was programmed to destroy
the future now his mission get down is
to protect it a lesson
we still haven't learned apparently what
have they done to my son survival's what
you taught me and thrill as they track
down the Conner family Sara the Che
Guevara of soccer moms with some big
guns and some big guns and John Hurt
nine-year-old son played by Edward
Furlong who would go on to star in
numerous court appearances did you call
moi a yes so witness an amazing
film with horrible consequences that
spawned a thousand lazy pop-culture
references hasta la vista baby
hasta la vista buggies hasta LaVista
Jessica hasta la vista baby
turn Arnie into a spoof of themselves
I'll be back I'm back I'll be back I
might be back you'll be back I'm
she'll be back I'll be back I did not go
to say that video that's what you always
say and let the film industry to
overvalue sequels stars and CGI that
still doesn't look much better today
when all we really want is a good story
about a hero who sacrifices himself to
save humanity even if it means leaving
behind the only people who ever loved
him what no I'm not crying I'm gonna be
crying it's just a dumb stupid action
movie stop looking at me
starring so much promise
I earn miles Dyson Budnik Alex Mack hey
Arnold
guns and roses gun in roses the only
Sarah Connor wasn't in Game of Thrones
Hank from Breaking Bad no really and the
FA's a terminator too bad they kept
making sequels
you know I'm all for self-sacrifice and
everything but you know you left your
arm back in the factory right that's the
exact same mistake they made at the end
of the first one you had one job bro be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers I'll be back the day epic voice
guy read one of your comments was the
most important day of your life but for
me it was Tuesday dark learn che che che
I ate my brothers turtle victory is my
destiny for the watch